china's y threatens catastrophic
catastrophic consequences if china is
confronted
they just seem like the friendliest
people out there um this is american
military news during the speech before
the virtual only davos world economic
forum she said that the world needs to
improve move away from what he called
the whole world mentality she also
appeared to criticize western nations
which have been adopting economic
policies and forming alliances around
countering china for example the u.s has
adopted the uger
forced labor act to bar imports from
china's
xi jiang region which are suspected to
being produced through the forced labor
of yogurt population the u.s has also
stated that international efforts like
the clean network which seeks to build
network infrastructure using only
trusted technology companies while
excluding companies like china's huawei
in september us australia and uk also
from the new defensive technology
sharing
agreement aimed at bolstering
australia's military capabilities in the
indo-pacific region
danielle thoughts
look he's
he's got until november and he's going
to do everything he can before the 20th
people's congress to bolster support for
himself not externally but internally
and i think we need to understand the
difference between the two because in
2015 2016 there was a global industrial
recession the manufacturing sector
worldwide got slammed china pumped a ton
of money into the global economy xi
jinping's looking for an unprecedented
third term which he hopes to become a
dictatorship when the 20th people
people's congress convenes in november
now he was born with the the actual date
of the congress is a very closely held
secret it's announced very close to the
date of it opening he was born in the
year of the snake people born in the
year of the snake october is a very
unlucky month and the chinese believe in
their lunar calendar deeply
so i say that sometime around november
or so all this tough talk is going to go
away all he wants to make sure is that
he retains his dictatorship so the more
the more he says about the west and the
west being the bad guys the more popular
he is on the mainland and that's what he
cares about does he stand the chance of
losing
there are enemies within and he has
there are some people who have
criticized his attack of the
billionaires
and
having gone too far in destroying wealth
in china and there are indeed in his own
party uh those who don't want to see
this this third on this is like fdr yeah
this is an fdr moment for china there's
never been a third term so he's trying
to exert himself within the party within
and by by breaking through barriers that
have never been broken through in
the the the the communist party john do
you have an opinion on this
i will not bloviate about what i haven't
researched so no okay i like that word
blow via go ahead i just want to follow
up with danielle you're saying are there
only are they limited to two terms in
china here it is the united states or is
this typically it is typically two terms
this is this is the 20th congress but
yes and they come together every six
years but this will effectively
ensure
the
the the strong leader who he has become
remains in this position and how long
and he's been brutal with his enemies
how long terms so they're six and not
four years in united states so he's been
in power you're saying 12 years
and he's looking for another six it'll
be 18 years and the chinese economy is
at a 30-year low growth rate 30-year low
and that's because of covet or why it's
because the country itself has has
reached its limits in terms of its
capacity to be the marginal consumer of
50 of commodities on the planet it's got
a demographic problem we talked about
that earlier and the growth is simply
slowing so any and all
stimulus that's going to be put into the
economy this year is going straight to
the people ray dalio's been talking his
book lately and he's been saying you
know it's common prosperity that's what
they call it this common prosperity push
the campaign it's a great thing for the
people of china well just wait and see
what happens after he succeeds if he
succeeds in november and then all the
the stimulus goes poof
look layman turns over here i don't
think there's any chance that he does
not succeed he's a complete strong man
and look at where china's at right now
you seem to be skeptical of him actually
winning quote-unquote re-election again
he has made there are people underneath
him you have to it is traditional right
now in china for you to name your
successor
that is even if he takes the
unprecedented third term he didn't name
his successor last time around meaning i
plan on being here yeah i don't get used
to me and that's what you know that
critically that's what he and putin have
in common is that they're going to be
around with their countries and with a
common enemy of the united states who's
around longer putin or she
in power who's around longer
what are their age who's not going
anywhere
it doesn't seem like she is either no
well we'll see come november
pat do you have any feelings on uh
whether she makes it a this third term
or not
i mean the way it's looking like what
he's doing but she's talking about a
system so six two it hasn't happened
i don't know this this guy seems like he
is a true believer in what he believes
in and he is one that imposes himself
um people and people are scared of
of this guy extremely by the way the
other day you saw how anna's cantor came
out and called out china again on what
they said about ughers and all this
other stuff then
um
was disappointed with what shaman had to
say on the podcast but uh uh yao ming
came out and said i don't know who this
enes cantor freedom person is but guess
what if you want to come to china we'd
love to show you this country stop it
and show you the yeah there it is he
says but if he wants to see the real
china come on down by the way here's
what i'll say if ennis decides to go to
china i would join him on that trip to
go to you and
if because to validate a point let's go
see how great about here's what i can
guarantee yeah there is a higher
likelihood that ns cantor freedom goes
to china then he goes to turkey
you're so funny you're so funny okay
maybe we'll you know what we'll do
here's an idea because i know this guy
that likes to travel
maybe we'll go check out the volleyball
team in china with uh john
and we'll do some investigative
journalism together what do you think
about that are you open to it
no so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]